die Nachrichten des Tages heute mit
Barbara halweg guten Abend und
Willkommen an diesem
fußball-wm-final-tag Norbert die
Spanierinnen jubeln ja 1:07 gegen
England ein schönen guten Abend auch von
mir schauen wir auf die Nachrichten
Themen des Tages
das Ende hochfliegender Träume neun Tage
nach ihrem Start zerschellt die
russische mondsende Luna 25 auf dem
Erdtrabanten
Aufruf zur Geschlossenheit im ZDF
sommerinterview fordert SPD-Chef klingen
bei konzentrierte Regierungsarbeit statt
Streitereien
ihr Glück ist kaum zu fassen Spaniens
Frauen sind erstmals Weltmeisterinnen
setzt die Königin ist aus dem Häuschen
[Musik]
sie sollten mitten im Krieg an die alten
Erfolge der Sowjetunion in der Raumfahrt
anknüpfen die erste russische
Mondmission seit fast 50 Jahren doch das
Projekt ist gescheitert die unbemannte
Sonde Luna 25 stürzte offenbar auf dem
Mond ab statt dort zu landen Christian
Volk hat Details
das Moskauer Kosmonauten Museum erinnert
an bessere Zeiten für die Eroberer des
Weltraums heißt das Denkmal auf dem
Gebäude Pilgerort für Raumfahrt Fans
doch die Stimmung nach dem Absturz von
Luna 25 am Boden
ich war wirklich bestürzt weil das in
der russischen Raumfahrt eine der ersten
Missionen seit Jahren war für uns ist
das schmerzlich aber unsere Feinde die
freuen sich natürlich Russland muss sich
jetzt weiterentwickeln muss zeigen dass
es stark ist dass die Errungenschaften
der sowjetärer nicht verschwunden sind
vor rund eineinhalb Wochen war das
Prestigeprojekt gestartet Russlands
erste Mondmission seit fast 50 Jahren
allen westlichen Sanktionen zum Trotz
zweimal nahm die Träger Rakete Schwung
um die Erde und machte sich dann auf den
Weg zum Mond doch kurz vor der Landung
bricht die Kommunikation ab die
unbemannte Sonde prallt wohl auf die
Mondoberfläche was bleibt ist dieses
Foto vor drei Tagen gesendet von der
Luna 25 es zeigt die Rückseite des
Mondes und es bleiben diese
Computeranimationen wie die perfekte
Landung hätte aussehen können doch
daraus wurde nichts eine Kommission soll
nun nach der Ursache des Absturzes
suchen
Armin Körper in Moskau da ist ja viel
nationales Prestige im Spiel wie
reagiert der Kreml auf dieses Scheitern
der Kreml reagiert heute mit einem
ziemlich lauten schweigen und das ist im
Angesicht dieser Blamage auch wenig
überraschend immerhin hat Präsident
Putin ja eine 100 Millionen Dollar in
die Hand genommen um der Welt zu zeigen
dass sein Land zu wissenschaftlichen
Höchstleistungen im Stande ist trotz der
militärischen Aktivitäten in der Ukraine
und vor allem trotz der Sanktionen des
Westens jetzt mehren sich hier die
Meldungen Russland könnte zu Gunsten
weiterer Mondmissionen aus der
Zusammenarbeit auf der Internationalen
Raumstation ISS aussteigen damit würde
Putin sein Land nicht nur auf der Welt
sondern auch im Weltall weiter in die
Isolation vom Westen führen
die Einschätzung live aus Moskau von
Armin Körper danke schön
der ukrainische Präsident bezeichnet es
als historisch die Niederlande und
Dänemark haben zugesagt der Ukraine F16
Kampfjets zu liefern Präsident selenski
besuchte heute beide Länder wie viele
Kampfflugzeuge insgesamt geliefert
werden ist noch unklar vorher müssen
ukrainische Piloten an den Maschinen
ausgebildet werden
schwierige Zeiten für einen SPD-Chef
seit der Bundestagswahl vor zwei Jahren
hat die Kanzlerpartei ein Viertel ihrer
Wähler Stimmen verloren die AFD hat die
Sozialdemokraten in Umfragen überholt
und der Bundeskanzler gilt als
durchsetzungsschwach im
zdf-sommer-interview geht SPD-Chef
Klingbeil in die Verteidigung Scholz
könne ja nicht andauernd auf den Tisch
hauen und rumrollen Thomas Reichert hat
mehr
es ist der Sommer seines missvergnügens
die Umfragewerte der SPD weit unten und
der Streit in der Ampel geht weiter dem
spd-parteivorsitzenden bleibt im ZDF
sommerinterview wenig mehr als ein
weiterer Friedensappell an FDP und Grüne
jeder der am Kabinettstisch sitzt das
ist ja ein Privileg auch diesen tollen
Land dienen zu dürfen indem man
Ministerin oder Minister ist und ich
erwarte von jedem dass man auch dann den
Pflichten nachgeht und dass man dazu
beiträgt und ich gehe schon davon aus
dass er das alle auch gehört haben und
dass wir jetzt sehr schnell zu einer
Einigung kommen doch beim Zeiten wenn
wir versprechen droht der nächste Ärger
2% der Wirtschaftsleistung sollen
mindestens für Verteidigung ausgegeben
werden Institute kritisieren die Ampel
habe dafür mehrere Milliarden zu wenig
eingeplant muss mir das genau angucken
welche Zahlen ausgerechnet wurden was
ich weiß ist das endlich die ganzen
rüstungsprozesse die häufig wahnsinnig
lange dauern dass die beschleunigt
werden unter Pistorius dass wir die 100
Milliarden Sondervermögen beschlossen
haben und ich erwarte auch dass das Geld
jetzt ausgegeben wird klingt bei selbst
hat sich im ampelring bislang
zurückgehalten so sehr dass es schon
Kritik gab die Position der SPD werde
nicht deutlich genug im ZDF drängt er
nun auf Hilfen für Industrieunternehmen
bei den hohen Energiepreisen ich bin
fest davon überzeugt dass wir den
industriestrompreis brauchen um die
Wirtschaft hier zu stärken und die
Arbeitsplätze hier zu halten und neue zu
schaffen ich nehme wahr natürlich auch
wie sie das die FDP dagegen ist dass der
Bundeskanzler skeptisch ist aber jetzt
geht es darum das zu klären und ich
halte das völlig aus dass es mal
unterschiedliche Meinung gibt zumindest
solange es ohne Streit gehe das aber ist
in der Ampel immer so eine Frage
das komplette sommerinterview mit dem
SPD-Chef sehen Sie direkt nach uns
ziemlich nah dran an Olaf Scholz und Co
kann man dieses Wochenende in Berlin Tag
der offenen Tür der Bundesregierung
Gelegenheit für alle neugierigen Fragen
oder Unmut direkt loszuwerden oder
selfies zu machen Klaus Brot weg
voll wie selten der Vorhof des
Kanzleramts reinkommt wer will mal sehen
was die Regierung so macht die
Kommunikation finde ich relativ schlecht
viele Bürger sind verunsichert ich denke
da könnten sie sich schon ein bisschen
mehr
aufeinander konzentrieren und einfach
gute Regierungsarbeit machen und weniger
der Kanzler muss darauf eingehen etwa
zum Krach um die Kinder Grundsicherung
insofern freue ich mich nicht darüber
dass es nun schon wieder so öffentlich
diskutiert worden ist aber wir werden
nichts daran ändern dass wir Stück für
Stück all die wichtigen Entscheidungen
treffen damit unser Land eine gute
Zukunft hat und vielleicht gewöhnt sich
der eine oder andere dann daran erst
dann zu reden wenn die Verständigung
gelungen sind auch der Finanzminister
bemüht den Konflikt zu entschärfen
vieles gelingen ja es ist ja leider
traurig dass über die Medien Sie Ihre
Frage die Punkte in der Regel in der
öffentlichen Wahrnehmung sind wo man
noch nicht sofort einig ist und wo auch
eine Einigung nicht vollständig
geräuschlos erfolgt die Stimmung wie das
Wetter vom Unmut den Umfragen regelmäßig
Messen heute wenig zu spüren solche
Formate sind natürlich immer
schön dass man sie hat und dass man
miteinander sprechen kann aber konkrete
Antworten findet man da auch nicht immer
sehr schön wenn noch ein bisschen mehr
Zeit gewesen wäre tschüss von der Bühne
ich bin noch ein bisschen hier eine
Stunde Heimspiel für den Kanzler nicht
immer sind Termine hier so freundlich
jetzt Fußball-WM Norbert Spaniens Frauen
sind erstmals Weltmeisterinnen ja das
sowas von verdient auch wenn nur ein
einziges Tor viel dieses Finale das war
bis zur letzten Sekunde der 105 Minuten
Spielzeit einfach nur mitreißend dank
englischem Kampfgeist und spanische
Spielkunst
ausgelassener Jubel und Tränen der
Rührung bei den Spanierinnen nach ihrem
WM Triumph
es ist so hart sich vorzustellen wie es
sich anfühlt Weltmeisterin zu sein man
kann sich das einfach nicht vorstellen
jetzt sind wir es Wahnsinn die erste
gute Chance im Finale von Sydney haben
die three Lion erstes nach einer
Viertelstunde laurinham trifft nur die
Latte lavoria Rocher mit mehr Ballbesitz
und guten Kombinationen mariona steckt
durch auf Olga camona Garcia
1:029 Minute der Abwehrspielerin gelingt
ein herrlicher präziser flachschutz der
goldene Treffer auch beim Public Viewing
in Madrid um judovic in der zweiten
Halbzeit ein Handspiel der Engländerin
Kira Walch Torhüterin Mary UPS hält den
Elfmeter von Jennifer hermo so Fuentes
dann ist Schluss in Sydney Spanien
triumphiert mit 1:0 die
Europameisterinnen von 2022 nach großem
Kampf enttäuscht Königin Letizia aber
singt und feiert gemeinsam mit ihren
Weltmeisterinnen den ersten Titel für
Spanien
[Applaus]
zweite Spiel zweiter Sieg der deutschen
Volleyballerinnen bei der Heim das Team
gewann auch ohne seine verletzte top
Angreiferin Hanna Ortmann gestern Abend
in Düsseldorf gegen Aserbaidschan
souverän mit 3:1 ein Sieg morgen gegen
Schweden wäre der vorzeitige Einzug in
die k.o.
Doreen vennekamp ist Weltmeisterin mit
der Sportpistole in Baku stellte sie mit
40 Treffern den Final Weltrekord ein und
ist die erste deutsche Weltmeisterin in
einer olympischen schieß-disziplin seit
neun Jahren
Alexander Zverev hat in Cincinnati das
Halbfinale gegen Novak Djokovic verloren
der Serbe gewann in zwei hart umkämpften
Sätzen mit sieben zu sechs und sieben zu
fünf
dreimal Gold für Deutschland bei der
paraem geholt von zwei Rollstuhl
Badminton Spielern Rick helmmann und
Thomas wannschneider gewann zunächst den
Titel im Doppel ja und danach die Siege
auch in den beiden einzelfinals ein
erfolgreicher letzter Tag bei den
European para championships
und zudem haben die deutschen Frauen
auch ihr zweites Spiel bei der Heim em
gewonnen gegen England
es bleibt heiß der Deutsche Wetterdienst
war morgen in der Südhälfte und im
Südwesten Vorteils extremer Hitze im
Nordosten wird es teilzeitalter teils
etwas wolkiger sonst sehr sonnig im
Norden 23 bis 29 Grad im Süden bei 30
bis 35 Grad eine Gellinek begrüßt sie um
9:45 Uhr heute journal das gesamte 19
Uhr Team wünscht Ihnen einen guten Start
in die neue Woche wir sagen danke und
tschüss und hier geht's weiter mit dem
ZDF sommerinterview mit SPD-Chef
klingenweiler banji